There's an idea in science called
the null hypothesis.
And it works like this:
when you're setting out to prove a theory,
your default answer should be,
"It's not going to work,"
and you've got to convince the world otherwise
through clear results.
So in my last video, while I was trying to
talk to a camera up on that zero-g flight,
the student researchers
all through the rest of the plane,
who were physicists, psychologists, chemists,
electrical engineers,
all of them were trying to disprove their
null hypothesis.
We want to see if brain-computer interfaces can
be used for very extreme situations, such as space.
and that zero-g or weightlessness will not
really interfere with the signalling,
and if it does, how can we filter it out?
In the flights, the participants are going
to play a game called "shoot-the-alien"
and they'll do so with their brain activity.
Simply put, they'll just think of movements
and not actually move
and by thinking of that movement, they'll
control a little cannon on a screen.
If I really move my right hand,
I get a certain brain signal
but if I imagine moving my right hand,
I get the exact same brain signal.
That means that I can learn a computer how
to respond to those brain signals
even if I'm not really doing anything at all.
That's why it's usable for people who are
actually paralysed
or suffer from other types of illnesses.
We're not actually reading someone's mind
but we're measuring their brain signals.
We have a cap, which has 64 electrodes
to actually measure those brain signals
through the skull,
and through a special gel that we put in.
The cap is actually quite comfortable
once it's on.
You don't actually feel it anymore so it's
just measuring there.
It's not going to bother them.
At least we hope it's not!
In theory, getting a negative result is
a good thing.
And for the BrainFly team, that would be
brain activity in microgravity
being too different for the system to detect.
Now, as long as the equipment worked,
that isn't a failure.
That just means your idea
has been proven wrong.
That's still a step forward.
But, in practice, humans don't work that way.
It's called publication bias.
Negative results are less likely
to be written up by scientists,
less likely to be published by journals
and less likely to make it out
to the rest of the world.
The media doesn't care if nothing's changed.
Scientific institutions have limited money
and getting flashy, amazing results that generate
lots of press coverage...
oh, that's good for your career.
So if you're putting all that
time and money in,
there is still a stigma that, if you get a
negative result, you have somehow failed.
We do hope to publish.
We hope to get, maybe at least,
four papers actually,
because we all have
different thesis subjects on it.
In the best case scenario,
everything works perfectly.
The BCI's still controllable, the data's not noisy,
all nine participants give perfect data.
That's the dream result.
My ideal result is actually this little tiny
brain signal called a P300,
which is a positive peak
in your electrical signal.
So what I think and what I hope is that microgravity,
the moment when you're weightless, may result
in a slight cognitive enhancement.
So up there, in those 20 second bursts of
microgravity,
those researchers tried to disprove their
null hypothesis.
For BrainFly, that is: is our brain activity
comparable in zero G?
Can you still use a brain-computer interface
if you're in orbit?
In a few decades, could astronauts doing space
walks use their minds to control equipment?
I'm not going to tell you.
You can look it up when
they all publish their papers
because the achievement is the same,
regardless of the results.
Science has taken one small step forward,
no matter whether they disprove
their null hypothesis or not.
Nah, I'm just kidding, they got the results
they wanted.
If you're a masters or PhD student from an
ESA member state,
and you want to be
one of the people behind me,
then have a look at the Fly Your Thesis program.
The link is in the description!